welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 11 daughter of
ferricks which sadly says goodbye to
Marva but hello to actual Wars and stars
that some viewers have been missing from
this Star Wars series even if you've
seen an original design of the 1977 film
just to put it right back to bed but
overall this episode was a delight of
Star Wars ship designs if you're looking
closely and there's just some really
cool visual details to appreciate from
this episode so let's break down
everything that you might have missed
Nicholas Patel's opening music changes
ever so slightly Episode by episode and
notice here the heartbeat thumb
percussion it's a soft electronic whale
over it
in
[Music]
compare this to the electronic whippers
of b2emo for whom this episode shoots
the removal and procession of Marvel's
Body by the daughters of Barracks but we
open on casting and melshi clutching a
cliff on our keyna 5 their hands and
feet chapped in bloody shoes and gloves
to things that would be helpful right
now and two things the series has
depicted regulated as part of an
imperial machine even now the Empire
forcing these prisoners to be shoeless
is something that they have to fight
through now the Imperial vessel that
they hide from is actually a tie Reaper
a ship originally designed for rogue one
it transported death Troopers to scarif
and since showed up in Jedi Fallen order
and other places the idea that death
Troopers could be the ones searching for
these Escape prisoners right now makes
this a lot scarier melshi says I can't
climb back up
you hear me I hear you my hands won't
work I said I hear you yes climb
climb Kino screamed into the prisoners
to escape mimic screamed it so they
could Escape aldani it's gonna be k2so's
final word and now Cassian encourages
melchi to climb and Cassian also says I
hear you an inverse to the nobody's
listening deafness of the Empire
nobody's listening being the title of
episode 9 and now she goes in the scene
from telling Andrew to stop telling him
they're leaving too tell me they're
leaving this is melshi's way of inviting
Andor to give him hope he's that's all
he needs to climb out of Despair and we
transition from Cassian and melshi
overhead on the cliff to a match
dissolved to an extreme close-up of the
liquid in the cup resting atop e2mo as
he watches the daughters of Barracks
work this transition has the effect of
superimposing casting to melshi
underwater briefly a recurring Motif
with Cassian as an aquatic creature in
these opening seconds we don't even know
really what we are looking at which is
really how grief can feel the daughters
of Barracks is a society of women who
care for the sick and elderly I suppose
a mix of Meals on Wheels and hospice we
hear their voices discussing moving the
sheets but leaving cassian's bed as is
because Marvel would have won it that
way it's interesting how these women
have a sense of what marva's will was
beyond her death and since she wanted to
be a rebel up until the moment she died
makes me wonder if she could have set in
place some deeper
more on that later but we're seeing all
this from B's point of view closer and
closer in his photoreceptor lens as he
takes all of this in now he has the eye
close-up does evoke Hal from 2001 to
Space Odyssey but in that case the
central red light connoted soulless evil
but here it's a red orange ring around a
dark pupil something closer to the human
eye that draws Us in instead of
repelling us B vibrates in the liquid in
the cup sloshes until the cup falls off
and Brasso catches it B is more than a
piece of furniture or a coaster he
emotes his own form of grief for Marva B
sits beside Marvis and to chair with her
cane leaning against it and her work
gloves hanging behind the closest
representations he still has of her and
we continue to stay inside from B's
point of view watching as the daughters
of Barracks carry marva's body out in A
procession adorned with plants which is
a rare color for this rust tinted town
we see Marva through a circular portal
matching the shape of Bee's eyepiece and
we actually see his shell reflected in
the dirty window lined up directly over
marva's body as if his spirit is always
staying with her and towing that card is
actually a newer model ground Meg sound
which assist unit which is especially
sad for B because if he was a younger
Droid he could say he'd be able to serve
as a pallbearer himself Cassie and Emily
come across some native narcanians the
pemilar brothers dual and freedy duel is
played by Matt Lyons who puppeted Dr
quad pond episode six greedy is played
by Liam cook who played Ochi of bestun
in ryza Skywalker their fishermen they
talk funny and it's just nice to see a
few more non-humans in Andor their ship
is a quad jumper the same type of vessel
as the tug B13 craft scene and Uncle
plett's jakku lot in force awakens
that's the one that got destroyed so
they had to resort to that piece of junk
the Millennium Falcon now these
fishermen haven't been very successful
only a few eels hang from their line but
they ensnare Cassian and melshi in these
sticky Nets and again we come back to
this bishmo tea remember Deja was
talking about casting her metaphorical
fishing net with Bix and Cassian is off
midliken with a fish the last episode
had to escape by swimming meanwhile
Dedra speaks for subordinates Via video
chat and I just like how what we see on
their screens lines up with the angles
of where the webcam would be for them
like for dendra it's a low angle pointed
upward an Adventures View you can see
the camera is further away to show all
three subordinates and I'm not sure if
daedra's video screen was VFX 10 in the
shot but they did add the reflection of
the screen on that black surface to the
console to the right of it the officer
explains the ferric's burial custom the
dead are bricked they mix your ashes
with mortar and local stone dust put
your name on and fire it up you become a
block of ferric's brick
they find you a wall yes
after the idea that the dead on ferrics
become part of the architecture of the
town the flat surface that Echoes the
best car bill twice a day and helps Echo
their 5050 metal ringing anytime they
want to alert each other the narcanians
comment on their catch noise
yeah I really love the cultural design
with the language there there's some
consistent Ned flanders-esque prefixes
on the interjections Mai zimai 2z2 Mazzy
my neighborino and I like how Freddy has
the stump arm with an attachable
appendage with the blade on it his other
hand is covered in residue and I like
that head played from an injury but with
long black hair and a bun behind it
there's just a lot of stuff going on
with this guy he's a true Feast but
since the Bounty is dead or alive duel
feels Mercy for them agreeing that it
was the Empire's fault of the water on
narkina 5 has been polluted to kill all
the fish claya meanwhile is using water
to spray dirt off a medallion another
extreme close-up of sloshing water in
this episode Bell enters the shop and as
the scene begins Claire refuses to drop
her into Steeler patter while her face
is in the view of the window only when
she faces away later in the scene is she
able to speak plainly now initially clay
and Vel are framed at the far ends of
their frames with lots of room behind
them creating an illusion that they are
alone in different rooms talking past
each other or perhaps spies sitting on
back-to-back park benches speaking in
code I also appreciate how clay has got
the Starkiller armor behind her backing
her up what you got Val padme's
headdress a toilet calacoric get the
[ __ ] out Bella asked clay what she's
done for the Rebellion lately and Cleo
gizmel her version of Lutheran's speech
last episode I don't have lately
I have always I have a constant blur of
plates spinning and knives on the floor
and needy panicked faces at the window
of which you are but one of many knives
on the floor what an image one knife on
the floor during a fight is chaos right
who's gonna grab it where's it gonna
slide next the tide can turn in any
direction but several knives on the
floor is that Amplified it's impossible
to know what's in play at any given
moment which way the war is gonna go and
I love this The Relic that they stand
beside is actually a real world Aztec
calendar also referred to as a sun stone
it shows the previous four worlds and
how they came to an end now since this
shop also contains Indiana Jones Easter
eggs these items are really just set
decorator nods not meant to have
continuity implications but uh sure yes
the aliens who help the Aztecs and
Mayans actually came from a galaxy far
far away a long time ago
our boy the time Grappler returns this
episode of bringing the best scar Bell I
assume this Bell is going to have some
importance in the pharynx finale next
episode now as Brasso prepares to lead
Marvis home a lamp remains lit beside
marva's gloves this is how they were
going to leave her home kind of a way of
keeping vigil beside this one
representation of her in the home Grasso
has this interesting line about Marva
moving on her life continuing and he's
referring again to this brick how it's
found a wall somewhere and again since
Marva was obsessed with continuing to be
a rebel in her Golden Years exploring a
tunnel crawl space underneath the
barracks Hotel hoping to overtake it I'm
hoping that that brick could have been
added to that tunnel like a keystone so
that knocking it out could crumble the
whole Tower or something like that it
would just be awesome if Marvis brick
could be thrown at someone's face
playing some pivotal role in a riot next
episode now there's only a bit of Andor
left this season so the tension is so
thick you could cut it with a knife and
if you had a kamikoto Japanese steel
knife you could slice that tension like
a professional chef kamikoto makes
Japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques kamikoto Builds
on over 800 years of Japanese knowledge
technology and expertise their Knives
have been meticulously handcrafted using
traditional techniques that date back to
the Edo period of Japan kamikoto only
uses Japanese steel each blade is
crafted using techniques that have been
honed and perfected by generations of
knife Smiths each knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
literal years to complete their expert
bladesmith's tone and shape raw steel in
the knives polishing and sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine Edge and every
kamikoto knife comes in this beautiful
heavy duty Ash wood box not only is it a
great place to keep your knife so that
it doesn't make your other knives
jealous it also makes Gummy Koto a
really great gift I mean whatever knife
you need kamikoto's got it there are
five inch utility knives seven inch
sentoku blades eight and a half inch
slicing knives and more the quality and
versatility of kamikoto knives is world
class which is why they're used in
Michelin star restaurants around the
world and kamikoto is running a massive
Black Friday sale right now and it's
offering new rock stars viewers an extra
fifty dollars off any purchase with
discount code new rockstars so go to
kamikoto.com
new rock stars to support our Channel
and get a knife of your own Bix
continues to recover from her sound
torture but interestingly what Echoes In
Her Mind isn't the dysonite children
screams again which we never hear it's
really the voice of Dr gorse describing
it beforehand they make a sound if they
die
if you're having difficulty speaking
does it take long the idea here is that
what is even more sickening to picks
than the screams themselves is the calm
way that gorse described them and we see
a close-up of that grid of six security
cameras the same type of camera is Han
and chewy shootout on the Death Star and
Bix sees the hollow projection of Anto
Krieger that's the rebel that luthin is
gonna allow to fall into the isb's Trap
and now it looks like the ISP thinks
that he is bix's contact the one that
they code named axis meanwhile mon
watches as their daughter Lata leads the
chandrillan girls prayer group with some
problematic sound enchanting yielding an
acceptance safe in the brain of the old
ways true and steady and rated interests
the old ways hold it safe in the not in
The Binding the old ways teach us bound
Against the Wind tied to shore tethered
in permanence safe in the brain of the
old ways huh cool you really don't want
to just play soccer but this gives us
some deeper context to latest hair
braids they are part of a chandrillan
Dogma to bound and confine themselves in
old traditions teched Against the Wind
or the undertow if this is laid his way
of rebelling against your more
open-minded parents she might actually
welcome an arranged marriage with pavos
golden sun now Vel is horrified by this
but mom tells her that this is trending
back showing how Imperial culture is
having a neoconservative trickle-down
effect on society now philosophically
this also contrasts the more natural
tenets of the Jedi code at least as
described by Luke in The Last Jedi a
balance that Embraces the chaos of the
weather in the crashing waves this also
makes us wonder if Leia organa's tight
hair buns might be part of a disguise
that she wears to feign adherence to the
old ways of Alderaan hence subservience
to the Empire notice howum Return of the
Jedi she lets her hair down breathe for
the wind to catch it lioness mossed from
earlier in the season called serial car
in the middle of the night mosque is now
working as a smelter still in Organa one
I like how Sarah waves his mom out of
the room I'm on the phone and later when
he steals some money from her safe it's
clear that all the characters are headed
back to ferrics for the finale back on
the Amos a few bluebirds fight over food
on the seashore find it interesting this
episode as compared to last episode no
one is hanging out on the beach this
time I'm thinking it's because all the
short Troopers kept finding bogus
excuses to arrest people and scared
everyone off instructionally I like how
this season is really retracing its
steps back we went to the bottom layer
of Hell on Arcana and now we're heading
back to miyamos and then in the finale
we'll head back to Barracks Cassian
sneaks into his hotel room while new
guests are sleeping to find his lockbox
with credits blasters and nemix
Manifesto
hey Renee require yes that was nimik's
voice there saying tyranny requires that
comes at the end of this orabesh that
you can briefly see on the screen it
translates to control is so desperate
because it's so unnatural tyranny
requires and I like this idea control is
desperate it's the opposite of what
Cassian told Kino last episode power
doesn't panic but both are true real
power does not panic but the active
attempt to control is really an act of
desperation Lutheran visits sargerara's
camp and runs into benthic two tubes
whom he just calls tubes one of the two
tubes brothers who shows up in Rogue one
also in the camp are two early model
x-wings these are not z95 starfighters
anymore because these have Astromech
droid ports and the z95s did not you can
also see Morlock from Rogue one
patrolling in the background saw tells
ludin that he now wants to join Krieger
on the spellhouse mission but Lutheran
tells him that he is letting the
spellhouse mission fail and Krieger to
get caught it's interesting how
Lutheran's showing his cards to saw
which signals to saw one how ruthless
Lutheran actually is but more
importantly bring Saul into the inner
circle of trust he's training him it's
your decision but know the choice we'll
let Krieger go down and play the long
game do we warn him and throw away his
sources taken years to cultivate yeah
this is a Sly test by Lutheran on saw
trying to get saw to take a leadership
role he's Luther knows that his days are
probably numbered but if he can get saw
to just start thinking strategically to
make these kind of hard decisions he'll
have a new leader among the rebel
extremists to rely on I like how Saul at
first just gets paranoid wondering who
among his partisans might be Lutheran
spies as well but Luther mockingley says
it's tubes just to prove this point
Assad that this exercise is a waste of
time saw at first says there's no way
out alive yeah he's referring to the
base right now but this also Echoes the
One Way Out chorus of last episode for
these Rebels really their One Way Out is
death Lutheran and claya have a coded
conversation about losing an antique to
another dealer but it's actually
referring to Cassian but Lou then gets
stopped by an Imperial cruiser arrester
Cruiser catwell class this was actually
designed from artist Colin Cantwell for
the 1977 Star Wars it was rejected but
was later brought back in the Imperial
recruitment video on solo Star Wars
story a nice tribute to Colin Cantwell
who passed away earlier this year
Lutheran sponder hallcraft send an
active alderanian transponder ID and the
fact that they use an alderanian one
might lead the Empire to increasingly
distressed Alderaan for having some
Rebel connections they use their tractor
beam on the front of it to draw in the
Thunder Hall craft but after the hull
craft can calibrate that beam Luton then
hits the thrusters a bit which gives the
Imperials a tug like a surprisingly Big
Fish on a line again fishermen and fish
but Lutheran intentionally pulls harder
knowing that these Imperials will have
to escalate the tractor beam in order to
reel him in this is part of his genus
strategy he's using this to Spring its
trap basically pulling back a slingshot
because when he unleashes that spray of
shrapnel now that the tractor beam is up
to five it turns that shrapnel into
bullets that slingshot it all into the
beacon dish and chews it up so then the
cruiser releases three Tie fighters in a
double pod Thai shuttle which was first
shown in Empire Strikes Back I know I
know I thought it was a tie bomber at
verse two but if you look closely it
does not have that lower bomb deploying
appendage also why would you release a
tie bomber in this particular scenario
Baloo proves he is one hell of a pilot
he shoots the shuttle first and then
takes out one of the fighters and then
he activates these two side lasers and
destroys the other two fighters doing a
barrel roll the kind of move that Anakin
Skywalker loved to do I'll try spinning
that's a good trick
Cassian calls zenwon who tells him that
Marva is dead if you look closely Zayn
has a bunch of screens showing a bunch
of familiar shift schematics on the
right that is the utilipede transport
which is actually created for Galaxy's
Edge in Disneyland if you go to
Disneyland you'll notice this thing has
boxes marked 70 80 and 83 these are for
the release years of the original
trilogy films and then over on the left
that's a corellian YT 1930 light
freighter similar but not the same model
as the Millennium Falcon Cassian and
melshi decided to split up so that more
people will find out what the Empire is
doing on Arcana 5 and Cassian is left
alone looking out over the water as the
sun beams through the clouds this visual
Echoes his future death on the beach
with Jen erso as a death star beams down
onto the scarif base this is where these
two like Lutheran said last episode burn
their lives to make a sunrise they know
they'll never see now my breakdown of
the finale episode next week will not
come out the next day because that'll be
Thanksgiving and we're gonna take some
time off so our breakdown of the indoor
finale episode will come out the
following Monday thank you preemptively
for your patience you can follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at a
boss Fallen Rockstar subscribe to new
Rockstar some more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]